[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département
[Musique]
vendredi soir à la bibliothèque
départementale se tenait la première
représentation de saâdi ma chance
l'histoire d'une rencontre tout en
chansons entre saadi une jeune femme
malgache et cécile fontaine une artiste
réunionnaise ensemble avec la
participation des agents de la
bibliothèque et raconte l'histoire d'une
vie et la quête d'un amour plus bras sur
une rencontre de ne pas les hits et
d'aller vers les gens parce qu'on ne
sait pas ce que les personnes procèdent
voilà et vous c'est votre histoire que
vous racontez associés
est ce mon histoire que je raffole à
cécile et je joue son propre rôle
en fait ce qu'on recherche à travers ses
traits à cette résidence d'artistes
qu'on met en place c'est de faire la
passerelle avec les publics entre nos
sites
nos sites patrimoniaux et la création et
au milieu de tout ça il ya nos artistes
réunionnais qui créer l'alchimie et
cette alchimie elle est parfaitement
réussie et on l'a vu aujourd'hui à
traverseront samedi après-midi s'est
lancé les marcheurs de la 11e édition du
relais pour la vie pendant 24 heures ces
équipes vont se relayer pour une bonne
cause la lutte contre le cancer
une manifestation qui a pour but de
récolter des fonds afin d'aider les
malades
le relais pour la vie c'est une
manifestation qui va permettre de
récupérer les fonds
mais surtout pour passer un message très
fort c'est à dire que le conseil ne dort
jamais c'est pour ça que pendant 24
heures
les gens vont se relayer ils vont
marcher ou courir à l'épaule amis poids
lourds est extrêmement important dans le
sens où le département doit accompagner
celles et ceux qui souffrent de cette
terrible maladie qu'est le cancer le
cancer frappe des personnes mais toute
la famille est touchée aussi et nous
avons une politique d'accompagnement
social de ces familles de ces mâles et à
travers notre présence et ma présence
ici j'ai voulu montrer notre solidarité
envers les malades envers leur famille
et leur dire que l'espoir doit vivre et
nous sommes là pour les accompagner dans
leurs efforts
[Musique]
dimanche 600 coureurs prennent le départ
de la boucle du bassin vital une course
de montagne avec comme terrain de jeu
l'espace naturel sensible de l'étang
saint paul franchement c'est un superbe
site on a voulu changer cette année mais
franchement le pas il est agréable on a
le montant aujourd'hui il ya le ya le
parfois on a fait le maximum pour mettre
tous les participants dans de bonnes
conditions
et comme tu dit effectivement ça super
[Musique]
jeudi acteurs publics et chefs
d'entreprise se rencontrer dans le cadre
de la grande journée du territoire avec
une volonté affichée offrir un accès
équitable à la commande publique aux tpe
et pme de la réunion les démarches
administratives simplifiées la
dématérialisation des allotissements
autant de mesures d'ouverture qui
s'inscrivent dans la stratégie du bon
achat le département de la réunion s'est
engagé depuis 2010 dans cette démarche
91% de ses marchés publics sont
attribués à des entreprises locales
oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui la place du
département est très importante quand on
sait que le département je travaillais
plus les plus de 1600 entreprises du
standard avec un investissement da qui
avoisine
on va dire les 180 millions d'euros si
on rajoute encore une fois les les 130
millions de propre au département plus
de 64 millions accordés aux communes
dans le cadre de ce de marché national
donc forcément le département a toute sa
place
[Musique]
le bon plan de la semaine s'adresse aux
étudiants le 30 avril prochain démarre
les inscriptions sur le site net bourse
les étudiants pourront effectuer leur
demande aide en ligne pour l'année
universitaire 2018 2019 sur le portail
du département plus d'informations sur
le www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]